[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
walt disney mettez-moi travaux distincts
non
obama
moussa
[Applaudissements]
thomas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand vous êtes là quand ils vous aiment
beaucoup où voulez vous rendre hommage
et ils vont tous rentrés en patineur
artistique
on va d'abord accueillir puisque c'est
avec les championnats d'europe de
patinage artistique
le couple allemand avec gilles verdez et
christine week end
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors franchement bravo bravo hyper beau
comme ça merci le couple albert siens
alors alors votez et commentez ont fait
un danseur ou alors on savait pas à quel
moment on allait pouvoir justement faire
leur introduction d'autant qu'elle a
laissé leur fait la droite du
championnat
il paraît qu'en patinage il faut pas
être trop bavard en tout cas c'est ce
que m'a dit l'ami philippe environnement
une fois pour toutes nelson monfort
mails sont moins forts rêvent c'est donc
ce que j'essaye de faire mais là à
l'évidence c'est quand même un leader
dans ce coup et c'est vrai une suiveuse
de qualité certes un petit peu quand
même un petit peu qu'ils sont en couple
à la fois sur glace mais aussi dans la
vie des commentaires regarde pas selon
l'expression consacrée
écoutez ils étaient cinquante sixième du
classement au moment où ils ont pénétré
sur la glace on peut espérer peut-être
une ou deux places en mieux on va faire
rentrer le couple italien c'est vous qui
allez les présentait donc vous enchaînez
avec qui alors un bon cher felipe nous
ambitionnons donc avec un couple italien
qu'il est inutile de présenter c'est
donc pour ça que vous avez nous les
présenter devant lequel angelo
accompagné de la ravissante géraldine ya
carbonara
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
allez pouvoir avoir les bonnes choses
parce que là
le tea party peu particulière
[Applaudissements]
kaka c'est chacun sait que c'est très
bon pour la ligne des patineurs c'est
pas mal et vous vous êtes est vous êtes
somptueux
par ailleurs cette manif richesse en
avait des communes comme ça à présenter
patinage fait encore plus d'audience ça
serait pas là ça serait pas mal tout cas
ça fait des cartons d'audience sur
france télévisions on le rappelle c'est
vrai que ça marche très très très très
fort allez pour enchaîner avec le
troisième groupe c'est un couple
espagnol
vous allez nous les présenter c'est vous
nelson alors oui nous attendons donc
vraiment et francesca pour l'espace
[Applaudissements]
de son décès sont les favorites de
compétition
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'ajc pas éliminatoire il peut se
rattraper le programme n'est pas
complètement terminée et philippe que
c'était favoris de la compétition c'est
dire le niveau est vraiment les mots
remo le pont de bois il s'est pris une
petite thalassa il a failli perdre la
moumoute
il a failli perdre sa couronne allez on
va accueillir le dernier couple s'est
axée sur les doyens de la compétition a
oui bonjour doyen de la compétition ce
sont les irlandais on voit pas souvent
des irlandais dans bratina j'ai fait et
j'ai donc peut-être quelques arrivées
d'eau véloce ton présente plus bernard
montiel qui fait son charme
[Applaudissements]
allez
à
mais s'est fait mal à la bbc tout
d'abord double gifle à la nage et s'est
fait mal et on s'en fout mais fait
doucement son besoin des voix attendez
attendez vous à déboîter l'épaule à la
paire larry cbl ah non mais c'est le
déséquilibre drapeau japonais s'est
mordu la lèvre ce qu'on voit là merci en
tout cas il ya des cascades dans cette
émission mais ils n'ont pas pu tester
tout de bras cassés